[Musique]
nous sommes au parc du peuple de l'herbe
à carrières sous poissy aujourd'hui on
va découvrir ce parc avec isabelle
chatou donc chef de projet aménagement
et valorisation des espaces naturels
on est perché à 13 mètres de hauteur où
on est là nous sommes parc départemental
du peuple de l'herbe sur la commune de
carrières sous poissy une propriété
classé espace naturel sensible du
département qui fait 113 hectares un
parc dédié à la nature la biodiversité
et l'accueil du public pour pouvoir se
promener se détendent profiter du
paysage de vallée de seine d'un site
voilà très caractéristique avec des
étangs des prairies des friches et vous
êtes très engagé sur la biodiversité
pourquoi alors l'objectif de notre
politique espaces naturels sensibles
c'est la préservation des sites qui ont
des caractéristiques écologiques et
paysagères très très forte
on a ici sur un site qui est dans le
corridor écologique de la scène qui est
très caractéristique de par la présence
d'insectes espèces d'insectes protéger
d'oiseaux également hivernants
migrateurs ou qui viennent édifié sur le
parc d'accord de quoi vous êtes très
engagé sur la biodiversité on va aller
justement voir ça à lille dès mars et
notre prochaine étape c'est ça oui tout
à fait et on s'arrêtera également sur
l'étang de la galiote
oui
[Musique]
le tout
où là on est dans votre endroit préféré
du parc on est où nous sommes sur la
partie centrale là où on a ce qu'on
appelle lé il démarre donc une
succession de marc installé dans la
grande prairie marre que l'on a créé en
fait de toutes pièces en décaissant le
sol on a amené une couche d'argile et
l'eau est venu très naturellement
ensuite on a voilà planté un cordon de
végétaux sur le pourtour démarré on voit
maintenant qu'elles sont bien colonisés
et ce genre d'aménagement ça sert à quoi
les mares sont très favorables en fait à
la biodiversité et à cents certaines
espèces comme les amphibiens ou
également les libellules voilà les
amphibiens sont des espèces protégées et
ils sont vraiment inféodés à ce milieu
et maintenant que le parc est ouvert au
public on va aller voir les activités
qu'on peut y faire
[Musique]
dernière étape de notre découverte de ce
parc l'étang de la galiote on va parler
d activité qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
ici de la randonnée de la promenade de
la découverte également du vélo on a 12
km de cheminement sur le parc pour
pratiquer voilà des loisirs de plein air
la scène à vélo qui passe par le parc
et puis vous pouvez également bénéficier
d' événements comme la fête de la nature
au mois de mai les journées du
patrimoine en septembre
et puis toute une programmation de
sorties nature au printemps à l'été est
enfin venir visiter la maison des
insectes avec des expositions
temporaires qui se renouvelle chaque
trimestre et puis l'exposition
permanente
animé par l'opie super et vous aussi si
vous voulez découvrir toutes ces
activités et ben vous pouvez tous les
jours c'est gratuit et accessible à tous